herzlich willkommen zufolge 204 des faz
einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 30 märz 2022 mein name
ist corinna budras ich bin berlin
korrespondent in der faz und an meiner
seite ist wie jede woche piano renz
freie journalistin und juristen aus köln
9 ja ich darf gleich zu anfang noch mal
die gelegenheit ergreifen auf unsere
umfrage hinzuweisen wir wollen alle sich
unseres kleinen jubiläums der
zweihundertste folge das haben wir vor
einigen wochen hin ja doch recht
zurückhaltend gefeiert zu diesem anlass
haben wir eine kleine umfrage gestartet
unter ihnen und der euch wir wollen
nämlich wissen wie sie unser produkt
finden unseren podcast und auf der
anderen seite auch unser faz einspruch
magazin das ja viele von ihnen und euch
auch kennen und da würde uns natürlich
das eine oder andere interessieren damit
wir besser werden können zu gewinnen
gibt es auch etwas damit verbunden wer
möchte ist ihm ein gewinnspiel und als
hauptpreis
winkt eine reise nach berlin zu unserem
live event am 13 juni in unserem schönen
atrium ja das nochmals hinweis den link
to ich in die show notes yahia und
ansonsten starten wir gleich in die
themen so machen wir es und wir beginnen
wie so häufig im moment mit einem
schwerpunkt zum ukraine krieg corinna du
hast ein sehr spannendes interview
geführt vor allem zum thema gas embargo
ja ich habe mit dem düsseldorfer
wirtschaftsprofessor justus haucap
gesprochen über das gas embargo über die
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen das ganze
wird natürlich ja etwas ökonomisch aber
ich dachte das steht uns gut zu gesicht
wir machen natürlich viel juristisches
aber ehrlich gesagt wollen wir natürlich
die große weltpolitik und auch die
ökonomischen auswirkungen nicht aus dem
blick verlieren und deswegen waren wir
uns mal auf diese
in diesem ganzen bereich des ukraine
kriegs gibt es aber natürlich auch
interessante rechtliche aspekte und zwar
kümmern wir uns mal um die strafbarkeit
des
symbols ja also z kennen wir inzwischen
auch schon viele des zeichen des sieges
für die russische armee ich finde es
auch ein bisschen gemein das tor oder
irgendwie so ein bisschen sein
markenzeichen verloren hat aber wenn
moment steht es leider in der tat für
das zeichen dass der angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine erfolgreich für russland
ausgehen soll absolut und inwieweit
tatsächlich strafbar ist dieses zeichen
hier in deutschland
ja irgendwohin zu hinterlassen
das werden wir gleich besprechen so und
dann gibt es aber noch ein anno themen
du hast uns was interessantes
mitgebracht werden ja und zwar geht es
mal wieder im weitesten sinne um
verfassungsfeinde in der justiz und da
hat der justizminister marco buschmann
einen kleinen vorschlag vorgelegt um zu
verhindern dass ich sage es mal platt
nazis laienrichter werden also
schöffinnen und schöffen werden das
schauen wir uns mal etwas detaillierter
an denn das ist durchaus wichtiger als
man auf den ersten blick meinen könnte
ja und dann hat der bgh auch ein
wichtiges urteil gesprochen aber das
müsstest du jetzt noch mal kurz
erläutern der bgh hat zu ein kutscher
daten entschieden und zwar seit jahren
schon streitig ob die daten die die
polizei aus sogenannten krypto handys
rauszieht verwertet werden dürfen um
menschen in strafprozessen zu
verurteilen der bgh hat sich jetzt sehr
sehr klar positioniert das urteil haben
wir euch mitgebracht dann haben wir
natürlich wie immer noch einige
nachträge unter anderem zum thema
drachen lord denen ja nun hier viele
treue hörerinnen und hörer kennen
dürften und natürlich ein wunderschönes
gerechtes urteil ja es ist wirklich ganz
ganz toll also das wird wieder unser
herz erwärmen zum drachen lautet
übrigens noch mal verweisen auf die
sendung die wir kurz vor weihnachten
aufgenommen haben das ist tatsächlich
unsere erfolgreichste sendung aber
gewesen ja zu rechnen das war auch eine
ganz tolle sendung ein anderthalb
stunden lang über die frage wie manja in
einem mobbingopfer umgeht der ja das
drachenboot zweifelsohne ist aber der
gleichzeitig auch straftatbestände
offensichtlich erfüllt also dass kommen
wir da kommen wir nachher gleich nochmal
dazu und jetzt geht's in die team
so bevor wir jetzt aber zu unserem
interview mit dem wirtschaftsprofessor
justus haucap kommen das hast du ja
gestern schon aufgezeichnet gericht sich
genau also das war am dienstag
dienstagnachmittag habe ich mich mit
herrn haucap verabredet und wir haben
schon sehr intensiv über dieses thema
gesprochen aber seitdem hat sich ein
bisschen was getan vielleicht noch mal
zur rekapitulation vergangene woche kam
eine knaller von wladimir putin als er
sagte mir er möchte künftig nur noch gas
lieferungen gegen grube akzeptieren ja
von den unfreundlichen staaten zu denen
deutschland ja ohne zweifel auch gehört
seitdem wurde intensiv diskutiert
inwieweit das bedeutet dass es wohl zu
einer blockade kommt der wirklich sehr
umfangreichen gaslieferungen aus
russland zur erinnerung wir beziehen ja
allein in deutschland hier 55 prozent
unseres erdgases aus russland aber die
g7 staaten am trotzdem gesagt machen wir
nicht mit dann hat gestern ganz klar der
beschluss der g7 staaten das sind ja die
sieben führenden industriestaaten der
erde die waren sich sehr einig und haben
gesagt wir lassen uns auf dieses spiel
nicht ein das ist ein ganz ganz klarer
vertragsbruch denn die verträge übrigens
auf privatwirtschaftlicher basis das
sind ja alles unternehmen die diese
verträge wiederum mit anderen
unternehmen russischen unternehmen
geschlossen haben die werden wir jetzt
nicht umstellen auf rubel werden also
dass den unternehmen sozusagen die
bitten quasi sich nicht darauf
einzulassen das ist so ein bisschen die
konzentration und dann standen die
zeichen ganz schön auf eskalation
richtig und dann war eigentlich relativ
klar da wird wohl ab dem ersten april
nichts mehr kommen oder nicht mehr viel
kommen ja also seitdem also und das ist
ja nun auch schon freitag
berechnet die westliche welt mit dass
putin den gashahn
abdrehte und dass es dann heute passiert
da hat putin ein wenig zurückgerudert
und hat gesagt na ja das werden wir
nicht komplett sofort vollziehen sondern
wir werden stufenweise vorgehen wie
immer auch diese stufenweise vorgehen
dann im konkreten aussehen mag das weiß
man natürlich noch nicht es ist so ein
bisschen zeichen der entspannung
jedenfalls auf dieser wirtschaftlichen
ebene und auch das vielleicht an dieser
stelle nochmal gesagt die militärische
ebene ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz
andere nummer und leider ist auch da die
situation so das ja von den spannungen
wirklich gar keine rede sein kann
und die entspannung ist ja jetzt dann
auch eher auf der zeitlichen schiene na
also man kann jetzt muss jetzt nicht
mehr zwingend davon ausgehen dass ab
ersten april schon kein gas mehr durch
die gasleitung läuft aber in der sache
gibt es ja erst mal noch keine
entspannung außer einem ominösen
stufenplan wichtig genau und das ist der
stand der dinge wie er sich jetzt
übrigens am
mittwochnachmittag
darstellt denn das ist der zeitpunkt wo
wir aufnehmen so
[Musik]
gleich zu anfang des faz einspruch
podcast werden wir ungewohnt ökonomisch
aber das hat natürlich seinen sinn denn
dieser krieg in der ukraine wird ja
nicht nur militärisch geführt sondern
auch wirtschaftlich und dazu darf ich
professor justus haucap bei unserem
podcast begrüßen erst hochschullehrer
für volkswirtschaft an der uni
düsseldorf und dort auch direktor des
düsseldorfer institut for competition
schön dass sie da sind herr haucap
auch schön dass ich dabei sein darf herr
professor cup seit wochen reden wir hier
in deutschland darüber ob wir dem
russischen staat noch gas und öl
abkaufen können nachdem er die ukraine
überfallen hat nun könnte es also schon
bald zu einem solchen in bar gekommen
allerdings eher unfreiwillig vielleicht
klären sie erst mal vorab wie konnte es
soweit überhaupt kommen die debatte ob
entweder nicht wir also wir im westen öl
und gas und kohle mit einem embargo
belegen sollen oder ob möglicherweise
putin beziehungsweise russland von sich
aus die lieferungen einstellen die gibt
es ja eigentlich seit beginn des krieges
das hat sich jetzt in der vergangenen
woche verschärft diese diskussion
sicherlich aus zwei gründen zum einen
weil man vieles andere schon getan hat
und ich kann die frage stellt was könnte
noch tun zum anderen weil ja putin
angekündigt hat dass er jetzt gerne in
ruhe bezahlt werden möchte und die g7
jetzt aber geantwortet haben dass sie
nicht in rubel bezahlen möchten jetzt
zum heutigen tag zumindest ist nicht
ganz klar wie jetzt putin darauf
reagieren wird
dann stelle ich die lieferung ein er
sagt dann drossel ich die lieferungen
oder ob er sich etwas ganz anderes aus
denkt ist womit dann noch schwer zu
sagen ich hätte den verdacht heute dass
er vielleicht nicht gleich die gesamten
lieferung einstellt sondern erstmal
bestimmte lieferungen drosselt aber die
psychologie von wladimir putin zu
ergründen ist nicht ganz einfach ja das
ist also von daher ist schwer zu
prognostizieren wie er reagieren
vielleicht meine technische frage
vorneweg das ist vielleicht auch eher
eine theoretische frage aber können also
eigentlich ist der mechanismus ja so
dass nicht die staaten selber das
entscheiden sondern die haben jetzt auch
nur empfehlungen an die privaten
unternehmen gerichte die das jahr angeht
denn der gasmarkt und der ölmarkt sind
ja privatisiert haben eine empfehlung an
die gerichtet und gesagt macht das nicht
also bezahlt nicht im rubel sondern
gemäß teuren verträgen in euro oder auch
dollar
und jetzt zu der vielleicht etwas
theoretischen frage aber können die
privaten unternehmen da auch aus
scherben oder hat die g7 da eigentlich
irgend welche druckmittel direkte
druckmittel hat die g7 jetzt eigentlich
erstmal nicht so zu sagen wenn jetzt ein
importeur sagen würde aus irgendwelchen
gründen bezahle ich in zukunft gern in
rubel dann steht sieben erstmal frei
seinen vertrag um zu stellen gleichwohl
halte ich das jetzt nicht für besonders
plausibel dass westlicher importeur seit
ich folge dem diamant hat auch immer
eher das gegenteil gesehen also viele
unternehmen sind ja auch von sich aus
schon rausgegangen genau jetzt haben wir
natürlich auch russische gesellschaften
oder sag mal der deutsche gesellschaften
in russischem eigentum die auch gas
importieren die also eigentlich im
weiteren zum gazprom konzern gehören die
konnten das möglicherweise machen weil
es ja erst mal private verträge sind und
wenn sich zwei parteien einigen vertrag
zu ändern dann könnten jetzt natürlich
erst mal tun dann müsste man also
irgendwie das sanktionieren von
staatlicher seite
aber letztendlich ist es jetzt erst
einmal so wir haben eine klare ansage
die g7 sagen da machen wir nicht mit und
dann muss ich jetzt putin überlegen was
er als konsequenz dann daraus folgt
vielleicht ne kurze frage was für einen
sinn hatte denn das was war die
intention von putin rüber zu schwenken
auf rubel also eben keinen keinen euro
keinen dollar mehr zu akzeptieren
sozusagen die unfreundlichen staaten wie
es ja nennt müssen uns in unserer
eigenen währung bezahlen hatte das nur
symbolcharakter also das zeichen an die
eigene
noch mehr um ganz ehrlich zu sein es
mein eindruck dass das schon viel
symbolcharakter auch tatsächlich dabei
ist denn letztendlich stellt sich ja die
frage also es gibt ja sagen wir zwei
möglichkeiten entweder der import von
gas sagt ich nehme jetzt meine euro und
tausche den rubel 1 und bezahle das gas
oder der gasexporteur sagt ich nehme die
euro die ich bekommen habe also wenn wir
den weiter euro gebe und der kann die
auch jederzeit in rubel umtauschen da
wird ja keine probleme haben seine euro
gegen rubel zu tauschen die wird eben
die
zentralbank wird von gazprom gehen die
euro nehmen und die noble umtauschen
also eigentlich er hat das schon viel
symbolcharakter weil dann auch ultimativ
für den wechselkurs des rubels wiederum
also häufig wird ja momentan gesagt das
dient jetzt dazu um die rubel nachfrage
anzuheizen und dann wird der rubel auch
gestützt aber letztendlich ist dafür
natürlich relevant wie viele von den
rubels werden den euro zu tauschen oder
wie viel von den euro werden in rubel
umgetauscht erstmal egal ob es jetzt der
exporte oder der importeur derjenige ist
der den den währungsumtausch
vornimmt also von daher denke das ist
momentan auch viel symbolpolitik dabei
ob das jetzt den ganz großen effekte da
bin ich so ein bisschen skeptisch auf
den wechselkurs des rubels ja sagen sie
aber das hört sich so ein bisschen an
als würden sie auch den bundeskanzler
olaf scholz etwas lügen strafen wenn ich
das jetzt schon so drastisch formulieren
da nämlich der hat sich auf den
standpunkt gestellt und er hat gesagt in
dieser diskussion die wir jetzt haben
nämlich dass wir mit wahnsinnig viel
geld jeden tag die
kriegsmaschinerie von russland quasi
finanzieren da sagte er dass stimme gar
nicht denn mit den devisen mit den euro
und dollar die russland gerade aus den
gaslieferung bekommt könne putin gern
nichts anfangen das scheint hier nicht
so zu sein
das ist nicht ganz richtig ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob er das so drastisch
gesagt hat von daher würde ich ihnen
jetzt nicht lügen strafen
wenn er mit denen die wiesn nun rein gar
nichts anfangen könnte dann hätte er
vermutlich den gashahn beziehungsweise
auch die exporte eingestellt wir haben
ja momentan auch noch kein total embargo
aller wirtschaftsgüter tatsächlich auch
wenn es ein starkes embargo gibt und
selbst wenn wir das von westlicher seite
aus hätten kann er mit dem euro oder
dollars natürlich auch in china und
indien immer noch sachen kaufen denn ich
gehe davon aus dass die weiterhin euro
und dollar auch entgegennehmen wir
hatten also von daher kann er natürlich
etwas davon machen wo olaf scholz der
bundeskanzler hat sicherlich in gewisser
weise recht hat
ist das für die
kurzfristige finanzierung der
kriegsmaschinerie er keine euro und
dollar zu brauchen scheint
mittelfristig vielleicht schon aber
kurzfristig würde ich auch dafür
einsetzen dass die nicht notwendig sind
die soldaten werden in noble bezahlt
dann mag man spekulieren dass die
söldner die ja anheuert nicht in rubel
bezahlt werden aber der westen ist auch
der einzige vertragspartner von dem
momentan devisen erhalten werden wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass china und
indien auch noch immer in
wirtschaftlichen beziehung stehen zu
russland und natürlich kennen wir die
bilder stehen schon die panzer fabriken
still weil ersatzteile nicht mehr
geliefert werden aber das hat nichts
damit zu tun dass es ein mangel an die
wiesn gibt in russland sondern dass die
diese teile einfach von jagow belegt
sind noch nicht mehr geliefert werden
also ganz egal wie viele devisen putin
jetzt also von daher ganz kurzfristig da
würde ich auch so ein bisschen davor
waren dass man da übertrieben hoffnung
hätte das wenn man den gashahn zudreht
ganz schnell der krieg beendet werden
würde also das wird eher mittel- und
langfristige wirkungen entfalten aber
nicht zum also vermutlich nicht
zu einem schnellen kriegsende führen
dass wir jetzt doch zu schön um wahr zu
sein das liegt daran dass russland zwar
am boden ist wirtschaftlich aber er ist
wahrscheinlich viel viel schlimmer noch
kommen müsste damit die bevölkerung
aufbegehrt zum beispiel oder was sind
das für szenarien die man dadurch spielt
ja die das aufbegehren der bevölkerung
scheint sich ja noch in grenzen zu
halten es gibt dieses schöne buch von
albert hirsch man das heißt abwanderung
und widerspruch oder auf englisch
accessoires und läutet die relativ
berühmte soziologen ökonomen die selber
emigrierte ist aus deutschland zu zeiten
des naziregimes und der hat eben ganz
klar gemacht es gibt ja für die
bevölkerung immer zwei möglichkeiten
also wenn es mir nicht gefällt dann kann
ich auch abbauen also ich kann auch
abwandern und da sehen wir einen teilen
auch dass teile der russischen elite
sich auch die flucht machen und auch
nicht mehr in russland bleiben wollen
also von daher
bin ich so ein bisschen skeptisch und
das scheint auch viele
politikwissenschaftler und russland
kenner ja zu sein die was den den
aufstand also eine revolution des volkes
angehen da hofft man besser nicht traf
also die hoffnung stirbt vielleicht
zuletzt aber also ganz kurzfristig sind
die zeichen nicht erkennbar so scheint
es zumindest sein und wer auch stand der
elite der das ist fraglich wann der
sozusagen wann der entstehen mir denn
die kann ich natürlich noch immer in
gewisser weise auch einfacher
zufriedenstellen die wenigen auch wenn
sie vielleicht tatsächlich unzufriedener
sind so ist das sicherlich auch zu
verstehen dass man jetzt etwa diese
sanktionen gegen die russischen
oligarchen verhängt hat wirtschaftlich
würde man sagen ist das ja irrelevant
was da passiert das geht ja wohl eher
darum dass man leute aus dem direkten
umfeld von wladimir putin unzufrieden
macht als dass man sagt das hat
wirtschaftlich wirklich effekt
vielleicht gucken wir uns mal die bisher
schon verhängten wirtschaftssanktionen
an also es waren ja die härtesten die
die eu jemals verhängt hat also es war
schon ein großes maßnahmenpaket
wir haben auch in folge 200 schon
intensiv über die wirtschaftssanktionen
gesprochen also jedenfalls die die
damals frisch verkündet waren was meinen
sie denn jetzt hiernach ist ja doch eine
relativ kurze zeit nach zwei drei wochen
aber was schmerzt putin am meisten
vielleicht noch eine kleine anmerkung
also der kollege peter von berge like
das ist ein professor an der
erasmus-universität der sich schon ewig
mit sanktionen beschäftigt er sagt wenn
man es ganz genau sind sind das gar
nicht die schärfsten sanktionen die
jemals verhängt worden die sanktionen
gegen den iran und auch gegen den irak
kuwait krise sie waren eigentlich
mindestens genauso drastisch wenn ich
sogar drastischer allerdings war es
richtig ist das waren damals
ziemlich unbedeutende sagen wir
wirtschaftlich sehr unbedeutende
nationen oder volkswirtschaften die man
da getroffen hat also wenn man russland
das ist jetzt die frage möchte man das
noch als große volkswirtschaft
bezeichnet oder nicht andere sprechen
von einem ökonomische zwerg aber wenn
man sagt ja gut das ist zumindest eine
größere volkswirtschaft als die von iran
oder irak dann stimmt das in dem sinne
dass zumindest gegen eine große
volkswirtschaft dass die schwersten
sanktionen sind die jemals verhängt
worden sind um und um ihr zu der frage
zu kommen was was trifft ihn am
härtesten da ist doch außer einigkeit
unter allen beobachtern die ich so
gesehen habe und meinen ökonomischen
kollegen dass sie sagen eigentlich der
ausschuss von dem zahlungssystem also
dass das der ausschuss vom trifft system
und das einfrieren der reserven der
russischen zentralbank das ist das wo
mit putin vielleicht auch nicht
gerechnet hat von daher dadurch dass man
jetzt selbst dinge die man theoretisch
importieren könnte nicht mehr
importieren kann man keine zahlungen
anweisen kann das hat russland hart
getroffen als volkswirtschaft als ganzes
also was eine gewisse tragik sicherlich
ist es für die allgemeine bevölkerung
dass insbesondere bei der
medikamentenversorgung es erhebliche
probleme momentan gibt weil es doch
viele importe aus der europäischen union
gibt wir haben das gesehen in den ersten
zwei wochen nach kriegsbeginn haben sich
die medikamenten umsätze mehr als
verdoppelt
das hatte zuerst den grund wohl dass
leute angefangen haben zu horten weil
sie angst hatten dass die preise steigen
würden sich zu bevorraten und dann
hatten sie die angst dass es bald nicht
mehr geben würde so dass also eine
unheimliche bevorratung stattgefunden
hat es ist kann sagen so ein bisschen
wie bei uns mit dem
speiseöl nur dass das eine ganz andere
zeit hat in russland weil das dann ja
doch eben die bedürftigsten in gewisser
weise dort trifft und die kranken und
ja dass das ist auch gewisser weise eine
tragik dieses krieges ist denn das schon
irgendwie bezifferbar also gibt es da
konkrete zahlen darüber wie sehr auch
insbesondere der ausschuss aus den
zahlungssystemen der der volkswirtschaft
geschadet hat oder es ist dafür jetzt
einfach noch zu früh das ist noch ein
bisschen zu früh wir sehen ja auch das
fast täglich noch was passiert den
ausschluss aus dem zahlungssystem es
gibt immer mehr westliche unternehmen
die sich zurückziehen auch wenn sie das
gar nicht müssten bisher nach den
verhängten sanktionen aber dies aus
reputations gründen einfach nicht mehr
für zuträglich halten noch weiter
geschäfte in oder mit russland zu machen
wir werden das jetzt zu einem einbruch
führen wird quantitativ ist schwer zu
sagen wir haben natürlich gesehen dass
der rubel kurs gleich um 25 prozent ein
gesagt ist die börse und das konnte man
nicht lange beobachten weil sie erst mal
dann sehr schnell geschossen wurde
sozusagen aber im grunde genommen sehr
schnell die die russischen aktienkurse
an bis zu 40 prozent verloren haben da
sind also schon darin stecken ja die
erwartungen dann was glauben die leute
was passiert das deutet also auch sehr
erheblichen einbruch der
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit haben in
manchen bereichen kann man es auch
beobachten leider einer der größten
automobilhersteller ich glaube
marktanteile 25 prozent in russland hat
die produktion eingestellt weil dahinter
ja auch renault steckt das heißt also
wir werden da
mit einen ganz gewaltigen einbruch der
der volkswirtschaft zu rechnen haben bzw
die die die russische politik und die
bevölkerung muss damit rechnen und das
trifft sie vor dem hintergrund in der
die russische wirtschaft ohnehin den
letzten sieben jahren er sich schlecht
entwickelt hat also ein armes volk wird
noch ärmer das kann man so sagen genau
also wir fokussieren uns jetzt häufig
auch die oligarchen usw die wenigen
reichen dies ergibt aber letztendlich
haben wir hier eine volkswirtschaft in
den vielen schon nicht besonders gut
geht und dem jetzt noch schlechter gehen
in zukunft da möchte man jetzt hat man
fast ein bisschen hemmung auf den
deutschen markt zu gucken weil das
natürlich dann auch jammern auf hohem
niveau ist das kann man nicht vielleicht
mal hier an dieser stelle konzertieren
wir wollen natürlich gleichwohl tun weil
es natürlich ökonomisch aber auch
kartellrechtlich ganz interessant ist
weil sich da ja auch einiges tut auch
von dem gesetzgeber her einiges tut
gucken wir also jetzt hier auf den
deutschen markt air spüren auch wir die
ersten auswirkungen des krieges zum
beispiel in den an den energiepreisen
der preis für ein liter benzin oder
diesel sind erstmals deutlich über 2
euro geklettert in der vergangenen woche
in das eigentlich noch mit rechten
dingen zu oder ganz konkret gefragt
machen hier einige ölkonzerne den großen
reibach wie es zum beispiel der
finanzminister aus baden württemberg
formuliert hat ja der große reibach
das ist nicht falsch
die marge der ölkonzerne sind temporär
gestiegen das ist so ob das jetzt ich
würde nicht gleich sagen das geht jetzt
nicht mit rechten dingen zu es ist eben
auf dem öl- und gasmarkt da herrscht
eine große unsicherheit natürlich auch
vor dem hintergrund weil die befürchtung
im raum steht dass ein embargo kommt und
keine öllieferungen mehr kommen werden
aus russland auch im übrigen keine
raffinierte produkte mehr also was
vielen nicht so bewusst ist von den
diesel importen kommen auch ein drittel
aus russland das wird nicht ganz würde
diesel importiert wie gas importiert
weil es auch selber in deutschland
definiert wird aber das erklärt auch
vielleicht weil warum bei diesel die
nervosität noch ein bisschen größer ist
weil da eben auch nicht wenig diesel aus
russland kommt und jetzt ist es
natürlich so bei den mineralölkonzernen
dass man sieht zwar die masche ist
gestiegen aber es ist nicht so ganz klar
dass automatisch gleich irgendwas
unrechtmäßig ist ist also was ich mir
nicht vorstellen kann ist dass sie sich
wirklich tatsächlich abgesprochen haben
also so doof sind unternehmen heute
nicht mehr wirklich sagen weil man weiß
ja welche geldbußen und
schadensersatzklagen damit verbunden
sind jetzt haben wir aber natürlich eine
situation gehabt wo der ölpreis sehr
stark angezogen ist man hatte auch noch
die unsicherheit wie wird das wird das
noch stärker
so werden wenn es denn cargo geben
sollte und da ist natürlich denkbar dass
die raffinerien auch eine gewisse
zurückhaltung geübt haben im abverkauf
von benzin und diesel wie gesagt diese
vielleicht sogar besonders weil man weiß
dass man da auch von russischen importen
nicht ganz so unabhängig ist und wie
macht man das sagt man möchte ich jetzt
doch lieber vorsichtig sein ein bisschen
weniger verkaufen die wir ein bisschen
mehr auf lager halten falls dann doch
dann bekommt man selbst den preis nach
oben natürlich so macht man das weniger
verkauft wird letztendlich und von daher
würde ich sagen diese reaktion das kann
eine reine vorsichtsmaßnahme gewesen
sein es kann natürlich auch sein dass
sie gesagt haben naja das ist jetzt eine
gute gelegenheit wir sehen den preis mal
nach oben und solange kein anderer den
senkt das denkmal denn jetzt auch nicht
weiter es gibt eine interessante
ökonomische literatur die sagt diese
diese schocks dies auch tauchen die
können dazu führen dass sagen obwohl
sich am markt kann ich gar nicht viel
verändert von einem gleichgewicht
vielleicht von einem wetters
gleichgewicht man zu einem anderen
gleichgewicht also hat korrosiven
gleichgewicht kooperativen leichtgewicht
kommt da gibt es interessante literatur
über raffinerie brände in kanada etwa
die dazu geführt haben dass plötzlich
eine art kartell also ein stillschweigen
das kartell nicht wirklich eine
kartellabsprache im rechtlichen sinne
aber und korrosive gleichgewicht zu
sagen mit ökonom also eine kooperations
verhalten entstanden ist obwohl
eigentlich sich der brand war dann
irgendwann gelöst eigentlich sich gar
nichts geändert hatte am markt und das
ist natürlich unklar was ist jetzt genau
passiert der bundeswirtschaftsminister
robert habeck hat ja angekündigt oder
hat zumindest das bundeskartellamt
aufgefordert sich das genau mal
anzugucken was passiert da jetzt der
verdacht liegt nahe eigentlich dass man
sagt die namen möglicher weise ihre
marktstellung ausgenutzt die
mineralölkonzerne und die preise noch
mal künstlich erhöht im zuge dieser
ölpreis ernährung also in einer krise
noch mal eine schippe draufgelegt genau
genau das kann sein dass es eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme ist aus angst vor dem
virus kann auch sein dass man einfach
gesagt hat jetzt machen wir uns mal die
taschen voll die gelegenheit ist günstig
und das ist natürlich die frage wo macht
man das am besten
ökonomisch gesehen ist das am
plausibelsten dass das an den
raffinerien passiert werden in
deutschland zwölf raffinerien die
kraftstoffe raffinieren und die sind
relativ verflochten untereinander auch
durch quer lieferungen unter den
verschiedenen mineralölkonzernen das
liegt relativ nahe dass man sagt die
marge fahren werden raffinerie ein das
ist relativ leicht zu bewerkstelligen
sein mal so was
unwahrscheinlich ist würde ich denken
ist dass das einer tankstelle passiert
dann müsste man 14 15.000 tankstellen in
deutschland koordinieren das relativ
komplex sein sohn macht eigentlich wenig
sinn wenn man sagt wir können uns
darüber die raffinerien diese zwölf
steuern das ist doch deutlich einfacher
weil der wettbewerb unter den
tankstellen das haben wir am institut
auch jetzt mal uns angeguckt der in
diesen ganzen preissetzungsmuster hat
sich eigentlich gar nicht richtig
geändert die zyklen sind nach wie vor da
die party tankstellen reagieren immer
noch eigentlich wie in alten mustern vor
dem krieg fast unverändert aufeinander
also an der tankstelle selber kann man
nicht viel sehen außer dass der preis
höher ist aber eigentlich auch dem hohen
niveau dasselbe passiert wie vor drei
vier monaten soll auf niedrigen niveau
basierte ist also der verdacht es
einfach besonders naheliegend dass das
einer bei der raffinerie passiert ist
und das ist dem kartellamt er jetzt auch
noch einmal aufgetragen worden oder
durch die gesetzesänderung wird das
avisiert dass man sagt bitte guckt euch
doch auch mal ein bisschen stärker die
raffinerien an wie sind eigentlich die
großhandelspreise das ist im grunde auch
einfacher als alle tankstellen zu
analysieren
und von daher ist der ansatz richtig
da müssen wir ganz kurz noch mal rein
gerät denn das ist ja eine meldung die
ganz frisch reinkamen heute am dienstag
wo wir das gespräch aufzeichnen also das
bundeskartellamt wurde beauftragt sich
diesen markt mal anzugucken in dieser
bestimmten situation daraufhin hatte
kartellamtspräsident andreas mundt
gesagt machen wir sehr gerne aber uns
fehlen doch etliche instrumente dafür
dass auch effektiv zu tun und jetzt hat
robert habeck schon relativ schnell
nachgelegt und hat am dienstag also
heute einen gesetzentwurf präsentiert
beziehungsweise der ist sagen wir mal
öffentlich geworden der faz liegt er
auch vor wo herr robert habeck vorsieht
dem bundeskartellamt mehr befugnisse zu
geben um ihm solche preisentwicklung an
den tankstellen zu untersuchen da gibt
es eben das soll konkret passieren im
gesetz gegen
wettbewerbsbeschränkungen und das soll
so geändert werden dass der auftrag des
bundeskartellamts angesiedelten
markttransparenzstelle für kraftstoffe
deutlich erweitert werden soll also zum
beispiel geht es da nicht nur die
preisentwicklung an den tankstellen zu
beobachten sondern auch die raffinerien
und den großhandel mit kraftstoffen das
ist das was sie eben schon erwähnt haben
halten sie das für sinnvoll
ich muss sagen sehr begrenzt aber ich
will das differenzieren also dass man
prinzipiell eine untersuchung der
raffinerien macht in deutschland das
halte ich für sehr sinnvoll dass man
jetzt sagt wir brauchen eine permanente
einrichtung die
permanent alle möglichen daten
einsammelt da bin ich skeptisch muss ich
sagen das scheint mir eher so ein
typischer fall zu sein von na ja vom
parkinsons gesetzt hätte ich das gesagt
also wenn sie erst mal eine institution
gibt die was zu tun hat die fragt sich
permanent was können wir noch alles tun
und wie viele mitarbeiter brauchen wir
dafür die wir dann noch beantragen
könnten damit wir das auch noch alles
tun also eigentlich hätte ich gesagt das
bundeskartellamt hat die instrumente
bereits es gibt nämlich das instrument
im kartellrecht der sektoruntersuchung
wenn man den verdacht hat dass es in
einer branche irgendwie
wettbewerbsdefizite gibt dann kann man
da auch anlasslos also ohne dass es
irgendwie missbrauchsverdacht in
irgendeiner weise gibt aber sagen wir
wollen diese branche mal untersuchen
dann hat das kartellamt sehr starke
durchgriffsrechte kann eigentlich alles
einfordern von dieser branche das
interessante ist ja auch sie hatten 2012
schon angekündigt eine
sektoruntersuchung zu machen und im
raffineriebereich das haben sich da nie
gemacht und von daher würde ich sagen
das kartellamt das bewundere ich sehr
machte die gute sachen aber sie sind
auch sehr gut daran immer gelegenheit zu
erkennen wann sie ihren mitarbeiterstab
aufmachen können von daher sie hatten in
der letzten gwb novelle schon gesagt wir
hätten auch gerne die die mengen daten
von den tankstellen wann genau tankt
tanken die bürger wie viel benzin und
wie viel diesel und so weiter und
eigentlich braucht man das zur analyse
des wettbewerbs geschehens sehr begrenzt
also muss man sich fragen ob kosten und
nutzen im verhältnis stehen und auch
jetzt ich halte das für sehr sinnvoll
dass sie die daten von den raffinerien
einsammeln
aber mit dem instrument der
sektoruntersuchung gibt es da auch schon
instrumente mit denen man das machen
könnte also von daher jetzt haben wir
eine krise hierzu haben wir gesehen dass
über relativ überschaubaren zeitraum von
nur zwei drei wochen so sagen da ist
eine diskrepanz gibt in zeiten einer
sozusagen großer großer unsicherheit
sich dinge verändert haben und dann
immer gleich mit einer gesetzesänderung
zu kommen da bin ich nicht unbedingt so
ein freund gleich eine neue regulierung
einziehen muss ich sagen dass
ja ich habe es an anderer stelle schon
mal gesagt aber ich wiederhole es
vielleicht mal gerhard schröder ist in
ungnade gefallen zu recht aber er hatte
einspruch der war gar nicht so schlecht
ja man muss auch mal die hand ruhig
lassen ja also liegt politik der ruhigen
hand man muss auch mal nichts tun
tatsächlich und ihr auch gesagt dann
macht auch bitte eine sektoruntersuchung
dem bundeskartellamt ändern da rauskommt
da ist so viel im argen wir müssen was
tun dann haben wir eine solide grundlage
in evidenz geschaffen auf der wir dann
eine gesetzesänderung machen aber jetzt
so hopplahopp die gelegenheit ist gut
wir machen eine gesetzesänderung dass es
mich evidenzbasierte wirtschaftspolitik
ja also das war doch ein gewichtiges
wort zum schluss herzlichen dank herr
haucap dass sich die zeit genommen haben
für uns ja sehr gerne sehr gerne es war
eine freude
das waren also die wirtschaftlichen
aspekte die uns hier in deutschland der
auch schon wirklich seit einiger zeit
beschäftigen und jetzt beschäftigen uns
seit kurzem auch irritierenderweise
strafrechtliche aspekte in deutschland
ja also es gibt auch immer wieder neue
probleme auf die man stößt in diesem
zusammenhang und da geht es um das
ominöse z ist es die eigentlich schon
mal über den weg gelaufen also ich hab s
life noch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
gesehen es ist tatsächlich nur auf
bildern
ich habe es auch noch nicht live gesehen
ich muss auch offen gestehen vielleicht
bin ich auch noch nicht genug
sensibilisiert ich für mich ist es noch
ein störfaktor vielleicht erklären wir
erst noch mal für alle worum geht's
eigentlich dieses set ist ja schon seit
einiger zeit im umlauf
schmückt russische panzer da taucht ist
zum ersten mal auf ein paar wochen noch
auf fotos die dann in den sozialen
medien kursierten und wo sich viele
fragten was soll dieses z eigentliche
auf den emblemen zum beispiel eben der
panzer tauchte dann auch immer häufiger
in moskau im straßenbild auf und dann
war kam die aufklärung direkt aus dem
kreml es wurde nämlich deutlich das ist
das z steht für eine russische wort
irgendwie ich habe mich ja schon geortet
ich bin es russischen nicht mächtig es
steht aber für den sieg ja also auf den
sieg es quasi eine russische redewendung
die jetzt durch das
symbolisiert werden soll und natürlich
geht es um die ukraine
und die tatsache dass man sehr gerne
möchte doch die russen gerne ihre
spezialoperation da wie es ja in
russland wer so
menschenverachtend heißt diese dieser
krieg soll also siegreich enden für
russland das ist also praktisch ohne
branding kampagnen für diesen
angriffskrieg das ist schon warum ist
das jetzt in deutschland ein thema ja
weil eben auch hier durch doch
zahlreiche russland versteher dieses z
in deutschland immer häufiger auftaucht
es habt auch
taufkirchen wird angemalt es wird auf
autos ukrainischer flüchtlinge gemalt
das ist vielleicht auch besonders
perfide ich habe auf twitter schon
gesehen dass jemand behauptet hat das
sei auch auf einer kinder frisuren also
ein rasiert in ein kinder habe er schon
gründe also wirklich es nimmt bizarre
ausmaße an und auch da nimmt man
natürlich anders das immer die gleiche
die gleiche message geben soll nämlich
rund für die russische armee und die
hoffnung auf den sieg in diesem
angriffskrieg so und seit einigen tagen
tobt die debatte darüber wie dem
eigentlich strafrechtlich herr zu werden
ist also ob das auch tatsächlich
strafrechtlich relevant sein kann und da
gab es jetzt die verkündung also oder
die ankündigung von mehreren
landesregierung die gesagt haben ja das
muss strafrechtliche konsequenzen haben
soll ich war verwirrt wäre
sehr verwirrt weil ich mir dachte seit
wann machen wenn jetzt die länder
strafrecht ist das strafrecht irgendwie
eine frage auf bundesebene sehr guter
hinweis
das ist es in der tat eine
strafgesetzbuch ist nun mal ein
bundesgesetz und geht natürlich überall
gleich und da muss man offen gestehen
das ist eben eine batterie die dann
vielleicht in den medien nicht ganz
durchdrungen wird und da wird dann auch
leicht werden zitate sozusagen
missverstanden falsch dargestellt also
es geht natürlich nicht darum
dass dieses zeichen verboten wird oder
neuer straftatbestand eingeführt wird
sondern es war eigentlich nichts mehr
als eine klärung oder ein wink mit dem
zaunpfahl also vielleicht um das
beispiel mal aus niedersachsen hier zu
zitieren da hat der innenminister boris
pistorius an die polizeibehörden ein
erlass gegeben hat gesagt personen die
mit dem z ihre zustimmung zu putins
angriffskriegen signalisieren die müssen
mit strafrechtlichen konsequenzen
rechnen also das heißt nichts anderes
als wenn ihr sowas sieht oder wenn es
zur anzeige gebracht wird dann ermittelt
mal schön ja das müssten die
strafverfolger doch aber auch von sich
aus schon tun oder nicht ich meine die
staatsanwaltschaft in diesem land ist
doch gehalten selbst zu ermitteln wenn
sie anhaltspunkte für straftaten sie dh
ist dass dennis straftaten ja der punkt
ist eben einfach folgender vielleicht um
das man auseinander zu halten ich würde
fast mal vielleicht zu anfang noch die
polizeibehörden in schutz nehmen oder
jedenfalls mal die theorie aufstellen
vielleicht für kombiniere ich so dass
man vielleicht auch wenig wie ich jetzt
am anfang da ein bisschen naiv ran
gegangen ist und vielleicht auch beim z
nicht immer die alarmglocken schrillten
sondern man es vielleicht irgendwo sieht
und denkt daher seit 1 so wie du es
schon gesagt hast ne oder auch der
zurich versicherung hatte auch das als
also es ist natürlich sz ist ja was soll
man sagen ja und das glaube ich diente
eben auch zur sensibilisierung und bei
dem ist ein straftatbestand so ein
bisschen in die öffentlichkeit gerückt
da geht es nämlich um paragraf 140
nummer zwei des
strafgesetzbuches und da es unter strafe
gestellt die öffentliche billigung eines
angriffskrieges ja um genau zu sein eben
die billigung eines verbrechens der
aggression und das ist ja nun ein
straftatbestand des
völkerstrafgesetzbuches um genau zu sein
§ 13 den wir hier ja schon mehrfach
gesprochen haben das ist eben etwas also
der straftatbestand der aggression das
verbrechen der aggression das etwas was
eigentlich eine ziemlich gute
beschreibung ist für das was wir jetzt
gerade in der ukraine sehen nämlich
quasi der brutale angriff einer armee in
ein land wo sie nichts zu suchen hat so
also dieser teil des tat bestimmt
bestandes dürften relativ
unstreitig sein er dürfte unstrittig
sein wenn ich ein set auf eine mauer
sprühe im moment genauso würde ich also
dieser teil es kommt noch mehr dazu und
zwar es muss in einer weise geschehen
die geeignet ist den öffentlichen
frieden zu stören so heißt es auch in
paragraf 140 und das ist jetzt nun in
den begriff ja also ich weiß nicht ob
man davon ausgehen kann mehr wenn es auf
so was ich in so einer ecke von der
mauer gesprüht wird keine ahnung aber
natürlich groß auf eine kirche oder groß
auf ein krankenhaus oder auch auf autos
mit einem ukrainischen
nummernschild ja da muss man ganz klar
sagen na das riecht sehr danach als
würde man hier ein zeichen setzen wollen
und deutlich machen möchte
ich bin hier ein anhänger zu sagen
russlands und vor allen dingen auch der
idee die ukraine platz zu machen
und dann muss es aber natürlich das
wissen die juristen allesamt muss
natürlich auch mit vorsatz geschehen das
heißt man muss auch wissen dass es sich
beim z um dieses russische siegeszeichen
handelt und nicht etwa um zerrung oder
den schweizer versicherer und das wird
dann eben im einzelfall zu klären sein
also natürlich geht es hier nicht um so
eine pauschale abhandlung aber ich würde
sagen es werden sich jetzt tatsächlich
die fälle häufen in denen die polizei
ermittelt es gab eben auch schon ein
paar fälle die jetzt durch die medien
gegangen sind ja also es gibt schon
eingeleitete strafverfahren richtig also
und zwar geht es zb eine familie die das
auf ihrem eigenen fahrzeug hatte ja und
zwar das zeichen z und eine russische
flagge also sie haben immerhin jetzt
keine anderen autos
gespendet damit oder gar ukrainische
flüchtlinge damit belästigt sondern das
war sozusagen ihr zeichen für die eigene
für das eigene fahrzeug aber
nichtsdestotrotz der staatsschutz der
polizei ermittelt zum beispiel in diesem
fall wie ich den medien entnommen habe
ja da werden wir wohl noch einiges sehen
in nächster zeit gut aber das vielleicht
zur aufklärung in zu diesem ganzen teil
denn es gab insbesondere in den sozialen
medien doch einige aufregung einige
verwirrungen und das wollten wir hier
deswegen mal klarstellen
ja und jetzt hast du uns was mitgebracht
wie gesagt es geht um die
verfassungsfeinde in der justiz ganz
genau es geht quasi um die
verfassungsfeinde in den eigenen reihen
und zwar in diesem fall ganz konkret um
die laien richterinnen und richter und
da hat der justizminister marco
buschmann von der fdp einen vorschlag
gemacht für eine neue regelung im
deutschen richter gesetz da soll jetzt
rein kommen ins deutsche richter gesetz
konkret in § 44a das nicht
ehrenamtlicher richter
werden soll wer das geht immer schon
drin gegen die grundsätzlichen der
menschlichkeit oder rechtsstaatlichkeit
verstoßen hat oder bei der stasi war
jetzt soll neu reinkommen wer keine
gewähr dafür bietet dass er jederzeit
für die freiheitliche demokratische
grundordnung im sinne des grundgesetzes
eintritt hintergrund der kiste ist das
ist auch nicht neu ist wird aber wohl
jetzt wieder verstärkt auf vor allem
rechte parteien wie die npd die afd
rufen ihre anhängerinnen und anhänger
immer wieder dazu auf sich auf solche
positionen als laster oder
laienrichterin zu bewerben und 2023 sind
wieder wahlen die wahlen finden im
antonius mäßig stadt ich glaube alle
fünf jahre in der regel zu chefinnen und
chefs nach wahnsinns jetzt weiß man
eines nicht genau ich habe mir das
nämlich jetzt auch echt mal detailliert
angeschaut weil ich mir dachte das
klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen pic ist
es aber überhaupt nicht wenn man sich
mal irgendwie klar macht was das
eigentlich bedeutet also man muss sich
erstmal überlegen irgendwie dass alle
richter egal ob jetzt professionelle
richter oder laienrichter natürlich
menschen sind alle menschen die
ausrichter banker sitzen haben
überzeugungen und die haben natürlich
auch überzeugung politischer natur es
bleibt auch nicht aus dass zum beispiel
ein richter am arbeitsgericht vielleicht
eher arbeitnehmerfreundlich oder
arbeitgeberfreundliche richter sind
menschen aber gerichte müssen natürlich
juristisch argumentieren und richter
müssen wenn sie recht sprechen
unbeeinflusst handeln und recht sprechen
von sachfremden erwägungen und zwar vor
allem von überzeugungen die den
grundwerten unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung zuwider
laufen das klingt jetzt erstmal total
hoch gegriffen das ist es aber gar nicht
wenn man sich mal anschaut was ein
richter und richterinnen eigentlich
ausmachen können und zwar vor einem
strafrecht ich habe mir da tatsächlich
mal so ein paar zahlen angeschaut es
gibt nämlich ein bundesverband
ehrenamtlicher nicht ordentlich und
demnach sind alleine im strafrecht über
60.000 chefinnen und chefs und her der
insassen über 100.000 ehrenamtliche
richterinnen und richtern in deutschland
das ist immer so das was man am ehesten
kennt bei den strafgerichten und da ist
natürlich auch am kasten weil wenn du
natürlich dass bürgerinnen oder bürger
dem straff ist dem staat gegenüber
stehst der dich an klagt dann hast du
schon echt ein interesse daran dass die
ein unabhängiger richter oder eine
unabhängige richterin gegenübersitzt und
die bei den strafgerichten sind die
chefinnen und schaffen in der ersten und
in der zweiten instanz hat es bei den
amtsgerichten und bei den landgerichten
tätig und da gibt es jeweils zwei
schöffinnen oder schaffen und ein bis
drei berufsrichter er das heißt vor
allem beim amtsgericht bedeutet dass da
sitzt ein berufsrichter oder eine
richterin das heißt er kann locker von
den beiden chefin oder geschäften
bestimmt werden und das ist vielleicht
auch eine neuigkeit für fielen also da
haben wir ein berufsrichter und man muss
ja ehrlicherweise sagen in den meisten
fällen gibt also ich fast immer gibt der
die der oder die die richtung vor und
weist so ein bisschen die schöffen auch
ein ja in diese materie sind ja wie
gesagt das ist ja der witz dass die
laienrichter sind so und
das ist dann kein problem wenn
vielleicht ein richter er sich da
eingemummelt hat ein schöffenrichter
sich da rein gemogelt hat mit einer
fragwürdigen gesinnung aber wenn es zwei
sind ja dann hast du dann würden zeit
schon richtig eng genau und das auch an
den landgerichten weil du brauchst halt
auch immer mehr hat ich glaube immer von
mindestens zwei drittel und dann haben
die laien richterinnen und richter hat
einfach richtig viel macht das ist
natürlich in strafsachen quasi am
schlimmsten aber es gibt auch sonst noch
in ganz vielen gerichtsbarkeiten
schöffinnen und schöffen nämlich bei den
verwaltungsgerichten bei den
sozialgerichten bei den finanzgerichten
übrigens auch bei den kammern für
handelssachen bei den landgerichten da
sitzen zwar quasi schon auf und
spezialistinnen oder spezialisten weil
das sind alles kaufleute es sind aber
auch laien richterinnen und richter und
eben habe ich gerade schon angedeutet in
der arbeitsgerichtsbarkeit erkennt man
das eben auch noch so ein bisschen also
kündigungsschutzklagen aber auch
verfahren über tarifstreitigkeiten oder
sowas dann eben immer für arbeitgeber
und aber nehmer innen jeweils auf beiden
seiten eine chefin oder einen scheffel
teilen die werden dann immer berufen
aufgrund von vorschlagslisten die von
den gewerkschaften kommen oder von
arbeitgebervereinigung das ist übrigens
auch überhaupt keine theoretische frage
denn schon im jahr 2008 hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
muss man sich überlegen das bis nach
karlsruhe gegangen und zwar gab es
damals ein betriebsratsmitglied von
daimler der mann war laienrichter ich
glaube in stuttgart irgendwo
naheliegenderweise und dann hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt das geht
nicht nachdem sich herausstellte dass
der typ gitarrist in einer nazi band war
ganz eindeutig rechtsradikalen texten
und damals hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht schon im jahr
2008 wo man nun wirklich sagen muss da
war sicherlich die ausprägung rechte
tendenzen in deutschland noch lange
nicht so stark wie sie heute ist da
haben die karlsruher richter schon sehr
sehr deutlich gesagt so nicht also leyen
ein richter und richterinnen sind echt
wichtig spielen eine riesige rolle und
wenn man sich dann überlegt dass es den
rechten gelänge dort systematisch leute
unterzubringen die prozesse politisch
beeinflussen dann hat das nicht nur
auswirkungen auf diesen einzelnen
prozess und auf diesen menschen der da
vor gericht steht sondern nur teile
schaffen ja nicht nur speckten im
einzelfall sondern die werden ja auch
aufgenommen von anderen gerichten die
werden zitiert und so so entsteht
rechtsfortbildung und diese gesamte
rechtsfortbildung würde dann quasi
infiltriert das kann natürlich keiner
wollen das wollen aber die rechten und
deshalb rufen die auch ganz explizit
dazu auf da gibt's dann so schöne aufruf
ich habe von der afg kommen die
irgendwie werden sie schiffe sorgen sie
für gerechte urteile ja ja sagen sie für
recht urteile nicht genau richtig das
kann man alles vielleicht nicht
unbedingt so wollen das heißt diese
änderung in 44 dadurch dass richter
gesetzt wer jetzt erst mal durchaus
hübsch das ist bislang nur ein
vorschlagen den hat marco buschmann
jetzt aus dem bmj erstmal an die länder
geschickt die haben dass es sich auch
alle angeschaut fanden das jetzt auch
alle man nicht total sinnlos auch der
deutsche richterbund hat gesagt jedes
das kann schon passen allerdings muss
man juristisch gesehen erst mal sagen
das ist er so klar stellen also das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat nämlich in
diesem fall des kanadischen zitiert
daimler
betriebsratsmitglieds klar gemacht auch
ein laienrichter muss sich durch sein
gesamtes verhalten zur freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennen dh
das ist eigentlich so es steht halt nur
noch nicht im gesetz aber jetzt kommt
frau eva kühne-hörmann ihres zeichens
hessische justizministerium die hat sich
dann zu wort gemeldet und gesagt mir
geht das aber nicht weit genug und jetzt
kommt tatsächlich so ein bisschen was
für jura feinschmecker die wir vier
zitierten jura nämlich der 44 deutsches
richter gesetz ist eine soll vorschrift
das heißt da steht drin dass nicht ist
ins amt eines ehrenamtlichen richters
berufen werden soll wer keine gewähr
dafür bietet das jederzeit für die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
eintritt ist das jetzt nur eine
juristische spitzfindigkeit man weiß es
nicht naja also nach dem was wir in der
vergangenheit gesehen haben kommt es ja
mitunter auf solche juristischen
spitzfindigkeiten an also normalerweise
heißt halt soll das zum beispiel wenn in
einer verwaltungsvorschrift steht die
benex exil onset vorliegt dann soll die
behörde so und so entscheiden dann
bedeutet das quasi auf jura deutsch dass
die behörde noch an der messen spielraum
hat bei der entscheidung also obwohl die
voraussetzungen vorliegen muss sie das
noch nicht so machen sondern sie soll es
eben so machen und genau deshalb sagt
die hessische justizministerin halt da
ist jetzt eine lücke tritt es müsste
eigentlich drin stehen es darf nicht ins
amt berufen werden so jetzt habe ich
noch mal im bmj angerufen da gibt man
sich so ein bisschen überrascht und die
sagen naja sie sehen da keine lücke die
fachabteilung dort gehen davon aus dass
das kein ermessen einräumt diese
vorschrift und die verweisen dann auf
die folge vorschrift der 44 besagt
nämlich wann richter abzuberufen sind
also laienrichter nämlich wenn solche
umstände nachträglich bekannt werden
wenn also der prozess schon losgegangen
ist und da steht halt drin irgendwie es
gibt kein ermessen so ist abzuberufen
also nicht sollen sondern ist man sagt
man na ja dann ist es irgendwie klar
dass es auch für die vorschrift 44a
gelten soll für die bestellung das ist
jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen eine
schräge begründung also das bmj hat auch
sehr deutlich schon gesagt naja
eigentlich wollten wir ja nur die nummer
zweiter ergänzen diese grund
formulierung sollen nicht ins amt
berufen werden die steht ja schon quasi
obendrüber wir haben überhaupt keinen
anlass dafür gesehen dass jetzt
irgendwie anders zu regeln als bei
anderen gründen warum man nicht
laienrichterin oder den richtern wir
hatten darf die wollten das jetzt gar
nicht unbedingt als ermessens vorschrift
verstanden wissen und der sprecher
meinte auch es hat noch nie jemand so
verstanden okay naja es gibt aber schon
auch ein sachliches argument wohl und
zwar dass das bmj ein bisschen angst hat
dass viele vor einem strafverteidiger
sich dann darauf berufen würden war ja
wenn da nicht nur soll sondern darf
nicht drin stehen dann könnten die
natürlich mehr besetzungsrüge erheben er
ist ein valides argument finde ich nicht
denn die besetzungsrüge die kommen ja im
strafrecht und hin
also am laufenden band vorne als
besetzungsrüge sollte man in diesem
punkt vielleicht noch mal kurz erklären
das ist so ein gängiges instrument
gleich zu anfang des prozesses dass man
eben da vielleicht auch mal ein zeichen
setzt und den anfang zumindest ein
bisschen aufhält und die besetzung des
gerichtes rückt er also ein bisschen
lapidar
befangenheitsantrag genannt es ist nicht
ganz aber naja so ein
befangenheitsantrag könnte ich dann
immer noch stellen es ist aber schon
geht in dieselbe richtung trotzdem
überzeugt mich das jetzt nicht so als
argument ich meine wenn ich als
strafverteidigerin jetzt ein
verhandlungstag drei herausfinde der
keine ahnung richter der laienrichter
der darf der auf der bank sitzt ist ein
nazi und mein mandant hat vielleicht
migrationshintergrund dann möchte ich
bitteschön auch die möglichkeit haben da
eine besetzungsrüge zu erheben total die
sollte sie auch kriegen ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass man versucht das
jetzt nicht zum standard instrument
werden zu lassen weiter in die richtung
in die richtung gehen dass auch
tatsächlich die argumentation des bmj
also ich muss ehrlich sagen mich
überzeugt werden und wir wollen auch den
verteidigern da nicht zu nahe treten
aber
natürlich auch sich vorstellen na gut na
ja ich würde mich als verteidigerin auf
jeden fall auch darauf berufen weil man
mit meiner besetzungsrüge dass ich sage
ihr müsst den typen jetzt abberufen der
kleine und dann bin ich ja wieder in 44
b drin das heißt dann habe ich wieder
gar keine hermès vorschrift also mir
kommt das alles jetzt schon so ein
bisschen konstruiert vor ich glaube
tatsächlich center grund einfach dass
das bmj hat die nummer 2 ändern wollte
das soll steht weit oben drüber da hat
einfach keiner drüber nachgedacht und
der sprecher hat auch gesagt na ja wir
werden jetzt erst mal die reaktionen aus
den ländern aus dann kann es ja auch
noch sein dass wir das noch mal anpassen
bislang ist alles nur ein vorschlag es
gibt nicht einen referentenentwurf und
wann er kommt ist auch aber warum kommt
der vorschlag aus dem
bundesjustizministerium jetzt denn das
thema hast ja schon gesagt ist nicht neu
wer das ist überhaupt nicht neu und das
ist auch schon von buschmanns
amtsvorgängerin von christine lambrecht
die hatte das auf dem tisch quasi das
kam ich glaube 2020 oder 20 21 auch noch
mal neu auf der vorschlag kam aus dem
landesjustizministerium in baden
württemberg christine lambrecht fand das
gut hat das schon so aufgenommen jetzt
ist marco buschmann dran bisher war das
aber irgendwie nicht so ein hippes thema
das war er immer so ein bisschen mit
spitzen fingern angefasst und so ich
kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass es
jetzt auch daran liegt eben das eine
gewisse öffentliche sensibilisierung
vorliegt weil wir ja diese geschichte um
jens maier kennen da haben wir ja nun
relativ viel schon darüber berichtet und
seitdem neben der afg ex
bundestagsabgeordnete jens maier zurück
will in seinen richter job gibt es ja
schon eine gewisse öffentliche empörung
zum thema verfassungsfeinde auf der auf
der richterbank und ich habe schon den
eindruck dass das durchaus auch der
hintergrund dafür ist dass man das jetzt
mal spielt aus und da sind wir auch
schon beim nächsten thema sozusagen in
dieser kategorie jens maier auch da hat
sie etwas neues gegeben
eine wundervolle überleitung genau wir
haben sich ja wirklich schon gefühlte 25
mal erzählt diese jens maier geschichte
grundlegend hört ihr da bitte noch mal
rein in die folge 192 5 12 januar wenn
ihr das problem kennen wollt also jetzt
noch mal in aller kürze jens maier war
bundestagsabgeordneter für die afg von 2
17 bis 221 ist nicht nur in seiner zeit
als bundestagsabgeordneter sondern auch
zuvor als richter schon extrem als
extreme rechte aufgefallen selbst für
die verhältnisse und wird im sächsischen
verfassungsschutz geführt als
rechtsextremist und dieser mann wollte
jetzt zurück in den richter dienst
nachdem er eben nicht wieder in den
bundestag gekommen ist das gab dann
einen riesen hin und her eine riesige
welle der empörung und erst dann hat
sich relativ spät das grüne
justizministerium eingeschaltet in
sachsen und das war aber alles ein
bisschen zu späten jens meier ist jetzt
erst mal zurück zu gericht gekommen und
zwar am amtsgericht dippoldiswalde mit
dieses kleine bestimmt total niedlich
amtsgericht immer irgendwie total weil
das jetzt nur ständig in diesem kontext
in der öffentlichkeit genannt wird aber
so ist es nun mal und als er dann am
ersten tag nach quasi dienstantritt
angetreten ist ist sofort ein
disziplinarverfahren eingeleitet worden
aber es konnte eben nicht verhindert
werden dass das er erst mal wieder in
den dienst zurück gekommen ist weil man
einfach nicht schnell genug waren aber
nun hat es dienst gericht ja entschieden
genau jetzt hat das dienst gericht
endlich muss man sagen im eilverfahren
entschieden also der hat jetzt erst am
14 märz seinen dienst wieder angetreten
und jetzt vor einigen tagen kam die
vorläufige entscheidung aus dem dienst
gerichten wie letzte mal hatten wir noch
beklagt dass sie sich ein bisschen zeit
lassen weil es eigentlich letzte woche
schon dann meistens gar nicht mehr die
zeit verschwimmen ich glaube es war
vorletzte woche aber jetzt ist die
entscheidung da wir deren fehlen wir uns
noch beklagt haben exakt es ist immer
noch nur eine vorläufige entscheidung
die kommt jetzt vom dienst gericht am
landgericht in sachsen aber das lg
sachsen hat dem fdp mann vorläufig die
führung seiner amtsgeschäfte jetzt
erstmal untersagt und zwar mit dem
argument schon schlag es sei naheliegend
dass er sein amt als anführungszeichen
af die richter ausführungs zeichen
führen würde sagt das lg leipzig die
haben das jetzt ganz interessant
begründet und haben gesagt ist droht
eine schwere beeinträchtigung der
rechtspflege und des öffentlichen
vertrauens in eine unabhängige und
unvoreingenommene justiz denn ist es
hinreichend wahrscheinlich dass sie ins
meyer von der öffentlichkeit die halt
mittlerweile echt alarmiert ist durch
viel medienberichterstattung und so
weiter als rechtsextremist wahrgenommen
würden und das ist eben was wenn das
vertrauen der öffentlichkeit erschüttert
ist in eine unabhängige justiz das kann
reichen die haben das gestützt auf die
nähe von jens maier zum angeblich
aufgelösten flügel der afd und haben
explizit dabei auch sachverhalte also
verhalten von jens maier herangezogen
das nicht zu aktiven richter zeiten
geschehen ist das ist gar nicht mal so
klar ob man das machen kann also ob man
ihn zum beispiel auch für seine oder
gegen seiner richterkarriere etwas zur
last legen kann was er im bundestag
gesagt hat aber das hat das lg gemacht
weil sie gesagt haben naja wir müssen
jene prognose entscheidung treffen ob
der mann sich künftig so verhalten wird
dass das vertrauen in seine
unabhängigkeit nicht gefährdet werden
und die haben gesagt für diese prognose
entscheidung können wir auch
zurückgreifen auf dinge die außerhalb
seines richter dienstes gefallen sind
und haben gesagt erst mal nix gibt
vorläufig darf der sein amt nicht aus so
und wie geht es jetzt weiter also das
ist ja nicht die einzige entscheidung
die da läuft es gibt noch ein weiteres
disziplinarverfahren am landgericht in
dresden das ist aber quasi in
parallelverfahren und diese entscheidung
vom dienst gericht aus leipzig die gilt
jetzt bis zur entscheidung über den
antrag des justizministeriums jens meyer
sofort in den ruhestand hinsetzen das
ist nämlich eigentlich der wenn auch
spät gefundene masterplan der da
verfolgt wird das man halt sagt man
möchte ich jetzt eigentlich den quasi
vorläufig seines amtes entheben bis
endgültig die entscheidung kommt dass
man den in den ruhestand versetzt und
dann gibt es ja noch diese theoretische
möglichkeit einer sogenannten realen
klage die der landtag einleiten müßte
hat es noch nie gegeben alles total
aufregend für juristinnen und juristen
deshalb gibt es auch ein gutachten vom
staatsrechtler professor christoph
möllers aus berlin das liegt
mittlerweile auch vor möchten wir euch
auch nicht vorenthalten wer das hält es
für möglich dass so eine richter anklage
erfolgreich wäre das geht dann um es bis
zum bundesverfassungsgericht das ist
dann wirklich richtig high level aber er
hat eben auch geschrieben das würde die
anderen laufenden verfahren unterbrechen
und hatte die richter anklage die hat
der landtag initiieren müsste dass wir
alles ein riesentyp haben eigentlich nur
dann für sinnvoll gehalten wenn das
dienst gericht in leipzig jens meier
nicht ohnehin vorläufig aus dem verkehr
gezogen hätte aber das haben sie jetzt
deswegen gehe ich erstmal nicht davon
aus dass da jetzt der landtag in sachsen
irgendwie per richter anklage
einschreiten wird sondern dass das jetzt
erstmal seinen gang geht und wir jetzt
mal abwarten bis die entscheidung kommt
ob jens maier in den ruhestand versetzt
also da ist in der tat viel los gibt
noch einen weiteren fall den haben wir
bisher noch nicht behandelt und da geht
es um eine berliner auf die richterin
wer ist das das ist frau und ich weiß
nicht ob du jemals zuvor von ihr gehört
hast du mir bitte ehrlich bürge mal sagt
winkler wirklich noch nie
also minimal in berlin könnte man sagen
ging das alles etwas schneller als in
sachsen da ist nämlich tatsächlich eine
andere ehemalige fdp abgeordnete
ziemlich unbemerkt von der
öffentlichkeit in den richter dienst
zurückgekehrt die ist glaube ich jetzt
am landgericht in berlin wenn mich nicht
alles täuscht in dem bausenat
und da kann man sich ja durchaus auch
darüber wundern denn ich meinen die
berliner senatsverwaltung ist ja
immerhin links regiert quasi und die
haben das wohl auch überprüft aber nach
den bekannten informationen das war ein
zitat nichts gefunden was es
rechtfertigen würde sie zu versetzen
oder ihres amtes zu entheben man muss ja
jetzt auch mal sagen frau ich sage es
noch mal muss ich ablesen frau birgit
mal sagt winkelmann kennt jetzt auch
praktisch irgendwie keiner das bedeutet
auch dass sie nie besonders aufgefallen
ist mit besonders radikalen aussagen
aufgefallen oder so ich habe das jetzt
nicht mehr geprüft aber der punkt bei
jens meier ist ja gerade der ist
jederzeit aufgefallen weil er eben sogar
für die afg besonders rechts war
besonders laut war besonders männer fand
wurde und auch das muss man sagen die
afd darf jetzt war das ist deutlich
geworden in köln am verwaltungsgericht
köln darf zwar vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden das ist jetzt geklärt
allerdings bedeutet das noch gar nicht
dass jetzt die fdp-mitglieder
irgendwelcher art von sanktionen
befürchten müssen oder gar dem
staatsdiener nicht beruflicher genau den
staatsdienst erhoben werden oder so weit
da sind wir noch wirklich wirklich lange
nicht dass man hier in dieser stelle
wirklich auch mal sagen also wenn man
hier sozusagen einfach nur afd mitglied
ist oder auch politiker und aber jetzt
nicht quasi wie eine rechte wildsau
durchs dorf rennt dann hat man natürlich
also was ich auch nichts zuschulden
kommen lassen exakt das ist eine
demokratisch gewählte partei und dann
darf man natürlich auch zurück in den
richter dienst also das wollten wir
jetzt auch noch mal klarstellen weil das
jetzt schon so ein bisschen wieder
medial aufgegriffen wird so nach dem
motto was ist denn da in berlin los und
natürlich kann es sein dass es
irgendwelche gründe gäbe diese frau auch
iris richter amtes zu entheben wir sind
aber bisher überhaupt keine bekannt und
allein die tatsache dass sie eine
ehemalige auf die bundestagsabgeordnete
ist reicht dafür selbstverständlich
nicht aus auch wenn man sich vielleicht
anderes wünschen würde aber es ist wie
es ist wir leben in amerika und ehrlich
gesagt ich weiß nicht ob man das
unbedingt wünschen sollten irgendwo muss
natürlich dass vor allen dingen
demokratisch und politischem wege gelöst
werden so aber dann wollten wir
vielleicht das hier noch mal zum anlass
nehmen für den wirklich bezaubernde
aufgabe des schöffen der schiffe noch
mal zu werben wie kann man das denn
gehören eigentlich ja wie kann man das
werden jeder kann sich ja darum bewerben
schöpfen oder schiffe zu werden und das
funktioniert relativ simpel man kann
sich nämlich einfach an seine jeweilige
gemeinde wenden da gibt es meistens auf
der website ein bewerbungsformular aber
auch ein formloses anschreiben reicht
dafür aus habe ich mir sagen lassen denn
ich habe heute extra noch mal
nachgefragt also grundsätzlich kann jede
oder jeder deutsche chefin werden der am
tag des beginns mindestens 25 und nicht
älter als 69 jahre alt ist es ist in
einzelnen gerichtsbarkeit ein bisschen
unterschiedlich aber das ist mal so der
grundsatz und ich habe dann noch mal
nachgefragt beim landesverband nrw der
vorhin schon zitierten vereinigung der
deutschen chefinnen und schaffen ich
habe extra nachgefragt das können auch
jura studierende machen und sogar auch
diplom jurist innen die irgendwo in
unternehmen tätig sind also
ausgeschlossen ist man wenn man ein amt
als richterin oder als anwalt bekleidet
denn es sollen ja gerade laienrichter
seien aber jura student innen oder auch
diplom jurist innen die zum beispiel bei
unternehmen tätig sind dürfen laut herrn
michael hasdenteufel noch eine tätigkeit
als chefin ausüben das wollten wir euch
durchaus noch mal ans herz legen denn so
kann man natürlich schon auch dafür
sorgen dass ein querschnitt von laien
mit recht spricht der die gesellschaft
auch wirklich repräsentiert man möchte
ich jetzt wirklich gerne mal dr wolfgang
maier zitieren der ist selbst derzeit
beurlaubte richter ist vorsitzender der
gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte und
selbst auch podcaster beim sehr
bekannten podcast lage der nation und
der hat in der ich glaube vergangenen
woche war das dann aus diesem anlass
auch so schön getwittert wäre ja
irgendwie nett es ist jetzt nicht der o
ton wenn halt nicht nur rentnerinnen und
rentner mit zuviel zeit irgendwie als
laienrichterin agieren finde ich einen
total wichtigen punkt was das heißt das
ist ja schon eine möglichkeit sich
sozusagen einzubringen und malen dienst
am rechtsstaat zu erbringen und so auch
ganz nebenbei das risiko zu verkleinern
dass seine feinde den rechtsstaat
unterwandern wenn ich das mal so
dramatisch ausdrücken kann und außerdem
ist es mal ganz ab von alledem
rechtsstaats geschlossen auch einfach
total spannend man kann sich wirklich
damit leider freigericht anschauen man
kann ja kaum ist es schon oft spannend
ich meine manchmal mahlen die mühlen der
justiz auch sehr langsam gebe ich zu und
manchmal gibt es auch super bowl ring
prozesse aber es lohnt sich es lohnt
sich für alle die interesse am
funktionieren des rechtsstaats haben es
lohnt sich für angehende juristinnen und
juristen natürlich sowieso und wir
wollten das einfach noch mal mit geben
es ist schon eine idee der man ruhig mal
nachgehen könnte sehr schön
jetzt kommen wir aber zu einem gericht
dass keine reifen hat ja wo sich niemand
keine laienrichter austoben können also
zum bundesgerichtshof so und jetzt musst
du uns nochmal einführen in denen enco
chat und den geheimnissen es damit auf
sich hat genau wir fangen mal vorne an
was ist ein coaching gesetz ist ein
unternehmen das ist so klingt alles ein
bisschen wie telegramm irgendwie nur in
krasser also engadget hat krypto handys
gebaut es ist wohl nicht bis heute nicht
so richtig klar wo dieser hersteller
eigentlich saß man weiß wohl nur dass
die in europa saßen saßen weil sie
mittlerweile dicht gemacht sind aus
gegebenem anlass die haben also sehr
sichere handys produziert ich sage das
einfach mal ganz neutral und haben sich
eben auch als als normales kommerzielles
unternehmen präsentiert das eben sehr
sichere mobilfunkgeräte baut für eine
sehr sichere kommunikation man konnte
mit diesen handys weder telefonieren
noch das internet benutzen sondern man
konnte sich nur mit anderen ankerketten
nutzern chat nachrichten senden notizen
anlegen oder sprachnachrichten
sprachlich da muss man aber schon doch
wirklich so ein bisschen alle hut mäßig
drauf sein und das machen zu wollen oder
wer hat weiß man wer sich dafür
entschieden hat für dieses wunderbare
produkt also der bgh hat nicht alle hut
gesagt aber der bgh hat gesagt
kriminelle unterliegen heißt natürlich
erst der letzte am ende der kette der
das gesagt hat zuallererst haben das
natürlich die strafverfolgungsbehörden
gesagt die fangen das nämlich nicht so
richtig gut die konnten natürlich nix
die konten nicht auf die geräte
irgendwie zu greifen die konnten keine
kommunikation lesen wieder inhaltlich
noch diese geräte auch nur orten und
genau damit wurden die handys natürlich
auch beworben und verkaufen in
anführungszeichen mit so einer art
anonymität garantie verkauft es auch
schon übertrieben denn man konnte diese
dinge gar nicht kaufen sondern die gab
es quasi nur im abo von speziellen
verkäufern hat der bundesgerichtshof
geschrieben sehr schön über anonyme
kanäle also bis man konnte jetzt nicht
irgendwie in den auto shop oder den
telekom shop gehen und so ein handy
kaufen sondern man muss sich dann quasi
mieten und zwar für den schnapper preis
von 1607 euro für sechs monate ok
verstehen und schon ab 2 17 28 10 fangen
das ermittlungsbehörden den ganz europa
irgendwie nicht so fern ziehen und fing
an diesen krypto handys mal nachzugehen
und relativ schnell setzte sich die
erkenntnis durch dass sind wohl doch
überwiegend kriminelle täter nutzen
speziell organisierte kriminalität
natürlich also drogenhandel waffenhandel
und so weiter europol war dann so
langsam auf der jagd es waren dann am
ende aber die franzosen denen das
gelungen ist die zu cachen und man weiß
bis heute nicht genau wie das ist total
crazy weil das nämlich in frankreich als
geheimakte eingeschlossen klingt ja
schon mal gut ja das ist wirklich sehr
sehr spannend das einzige was man weiß
ist dass es irgendwie den ermittlern
nach einigen erfolglosen versuchen
gelungen ist da wohl malware darauf zu
spielen mit richterlicher genehmigung
aus frankreich muss man sagen und dann
kamen die da so eine abfang
einrichtungen eingerichtet und konnten
auf die passworte der krypto handys
zugreifen sie dann ändern und dann waren
sie dran jedenfalls sind sie dann so an
die kommunikationsinhalte gelangt und
damit natürlich auch an die daten von
wirklich sehr vielen nutzerinnen und
nutzern die diese telefone halt genutzt
hatten wie gesagt mehr weiß man nicht
staatsgeheimnis in frankreich so und
dann kamen diese daten über europol 2020
auch an deutsche ermittlungsbehörden die
haben dann natürlich angefangen in
deutschland zu ermitteln auch das wohl
soweit alles in ordnung gelaufen da hat
ein französisches gericht irgendwie
diese übermittlung nach deutschland und
die verwendung in deutschen
strafverfahren noch erlaubt und trotzdem
ging natürlich sofort riesen diskussion
los
und die frage war kann man jetzt diese
daten die so erlangt worden sind in
strafverfahren verwerten und genau diese
frage ist jetzt auch zum
bundesgerichtshof gegangen also da ist
ein mann verurteilt worden wegen handels
mit betäubungsmitteln in immerhin zehn
fälle der ist auch verurteilt worden zu
fünf jahren haft und der ist jetzt bis
zum bgh gegangen und war eben der
auffassung diese daten die ihr so
bekommen habt hättet ihr nicht als
beweismittel verwenden gegen dürfen
gegen mich und damit war nicht alleine
also das haben viele
datenschutzrechtliche vor allem aber
auch viele strafrechtlerin und
strafrechtler so gesehen und gesagt es
muss einem beweisverwertungsverbot
unterliegen weil ihr da quasi eine
anlasslose massen immer wach ung
durchgeführt habt auch unverletzt
unverdächtiger nutzer und das muss quasi
durchschlagen und darf dann in den
rechtsstaatlichen strafverfahren nicht
gegen die angeklagten verwendet werden
ja andere an sich der bgh
also da sind sie wirklich krachend
gescheitert muss man sagen die leipziger
richter das war der fünfte strafsenat
dieses jahr in leipzig nicht in
karlsruhe haben sie ja deutlich gesagt
sie sehen ich zitiere unter keinem
rechtlichen gesichtspunkt ein
beweisverwertungsverbot
jedenfalls dann nicht wenn es um die
aufklärung besonders schwerer straftaten
geht denn der bgh sagt natürlich schon
heimlich von behörden aufgezeichnete
kommunikationsinhalte das ist klar das
ist ein eingriff in das
fernmeldegeheimnis also artikel 10 des
grundgesetzes deshalb muss der
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz besonders
beachtet werden das heißt man darf das
nur verwenden wenn es um wirklich
schwere straftaten geht und die richter
orientieren sich da am 100e absatz 6
nummer eins ja ja ich weiß sehr genau
der strafprozessordnung das ist so ein
dass in katalog straftaten besonders
schwere straftaten zu deren aufklärung
die polizei zum beispiel auch die
online-durchsuchung machen darf oder
wohnräume akustisch überwachen darf also
das sind quasi wirklich die die legte
die die krassesten eingriffe
rechtfertigen und diesen katalog nimmt
der bgh und sagt na ja da stehen auch
verbrechen nach dem
betäubungsmittelgesetz drin wie sie hier
dem angeklagten in diesem verfahren zur
last gelegt werden das ist so ein
schweres verbrechen deswegen geht das
hier klar okay gut also da haben wir
jetzt endlich in dieser frage klarheit
dürften relativ kleinen kreis betreffen
neuer so wenige waren das gar nicht und
es ist schon wirklich ein deutliches
urteil der bgh sagt mich am ende neben
sehr vielen anderen das urteil 70 seiten
lang oder so aber am ende sagt der bgh
das war keine anlasslose überwachung und
verdächtiger handynutzer sondern schon
zum zeitpunkt dieser überwachung hätten
die ermittler einfach genug hinweise
dafür gehabt dass sie ein gutschein
telefone vornehmlich kriminellen
aktivitäten dienten das könne kein
besonders waren so teuer es gab keinen
normalen vertriebsweg und die nutzer
seien schon deswegen verdächtig gewesen
per sie sozusagen weil sie ein quad
handys benutzt haben
[Musik]
ja dann sind wir jetzt beim drachen lord
vielleicht noch mal kurz zur
rekapitulation dass es eben dieser
mensch auf youtube er unter dem
pseudonym drachen lord der schon seit
jahren einerseits für aufregung sorgt ja
durchaus da provoziert mit sehr
merkwürdigen beiträgen mit sehr vulgärer
sprache und gleichzeitig aber auch ganz
zweifellos ja opfer von hass wurde von
er auch physischer gewalt der hass es ja
nicht nur online geblieben das ganze
begann online aber irgendwann ist es
völlig eskaliert und die sogenannten
hater die nennen sich selber so also
hater auf hessisch quasi sind dann in
dem dorf und am haus von rainer w das
ist ein richtiger name wenn er sich
nicht gerade doch im lot nennt
aufgekreuzt die haben ihn da provoziert
die sind auf sein grundstück
eingedrungen und so weiter und das über
jahren und nun hat es wirklich ja auch
bundesweit totale aufmerksamkeit
bekommen weil der drachen laut sich
selber vor gericht verantworten musste
denn bei diesen auseinandersetzungen gab
es immer wieder auch handgreiflichkeiten
auch er ist ausgerastet auch er hat
körperverletzung begangen das heißt wir
haben es hier nicht nur im fall also
nicht nur gegen ihn sondern auch gegen
die händler selbst mit einer fülle von
astral zu tun wie gesagt das haben wir
alles rekapituliert in unserer folge vor
weihnachten ja und jetzt gab es eben ein
urteil über das wir damals gesprochen
habe und nun kam die nächste instanz
und was ist da passiert
genau damals haben wir gesprochen über
das urteil des amtsgerichts das
amtsgericht hatte den drachen lord
verurteilt zu zwei jahren und zwar ohne
bewährung man muss dazu wissen bei den
körperverletzungen wegen denen er jetzt
verurteilt wurde war er schon auf
bewährung draußen also das war nicht das
erste mal und da hat das hat das
amtsgericht ihm auch relativ stark zur
last gelegt und das hat ihm jetzt auch
zweitinstanzlich in seiner berufung der
staatsanwaltschaft zur last gelegt und
hatte eine wesentlich höhere strafe
gefordert aber das landgericht hat ihn
jetzt milder verurteilt das hat bis das
heißt bislang hat rainer w jetzt
gewonnen also er hat jetzt mal ein jahr
auf bewährung bekommen soll eine
geldauflage zahlen ich glaube 2500 euro
und ja das ging jetzt ein bisschen unter
in der medialen berichterstattung er hat
auch ein medientraining aufgebrummt
bekommen das könnte wohl auch nicht
schaden was das bringen kann kann man
sich noch mal fragen aber auch dieser
prozess muss wieder relativ absurd
abgelaufen sein es hat kollegen die elf
oder zwölf stücken gehört die
verhandlung es waren diverse händler vor
ort die haben sich da eben mit hinten
rein gesetzt die man vor gericht zwar
natürlich auch haider als zeugen geladen
einer von denen ist hat auch als zeuge
ausgesagt war offenkundig dabei
betrunken ist nicht da vor dem
gerichtsgebäude noch ausfällig geworden
abgeführt worden und so weiter und
darauf hat der richter auch ein bisschen
das urteil stützt natürlich nicht auf
diesen speziellen hater sondern diese
verhältnismäßige milder hat es schon
auch damit begründet dass er gesagt hat
diese hacker haben die konfrontation die
zu den körperverletzungen geführt haben
ganz bewusst herbeigeführt und heben das
ist jetzt nur eine bewährungsstrafe
gegeben hat für rainer w hatte damit
begründet dass man in der justiz diese
art der nachstellung nicht kennen es hat
wohl auch mit us daten gegeben über den
geistigen zustand von rainer w das wurde
allerdings nicht öffentlich erstattet um
den eltern eben nicht noch mehr futter
zu geben die urteilsgründe liegen auch
noch nicht vor ich habe heute noch mal
nachgefragt beim landgericht in nürnberg
die gips noch nicht das heißt wir können
noch nicht mehr dazu sagen der richter
hat rainer w aber noch einen rat mit
gegeben üben sie zurückhaltend
die so unauffällig wie möglich man muss
sagen dass der drachen lord in
anführungszeichen sich mühe gibt also
hat immerhin mittlerweile sein haus
verkauft die sogenannte drachen schanze
und hat ja damit den händlern noch quasi
den pilgerort weggenommen wo sie
hinfahren könnten um ihn zu provozieren
derzeit ist er wohl unterwegs in einem
hellblauen pickup wenn ich das nie
verstanden habe er sendet auf jeden fall
immer noch youtube videos
das ganze ist noch nicht das ende der
geschichte das steht ja fest die
staatsanwaltschaft hat auf jeden fall
schon revision eingelegt die hatten zwei
jahre und drei monate ohne bewährung
gefordert und nicht gekommen wie gesagt
mit der begründung der typ ist
vorbestraft und hatte eben die ihm jetzt
abgeurteilten straftaten unter bewährung
begangen und jetzt wird das bayerische
oberste landesgericht noch mal
entscheiden und ich glaube man darf auch
sehr gespannt sein wie es weitergeht
denn die hater veranstalten wohl schon
so eine art schnitzeljagd wo denn wohl
reiner wie sich aufhält mit seinem
hellblauen pick up das ist vielleicht
noch mal ein wichtiger hinweis nur weil
bei revision denkt man immer sofort ans
bund an den bundesgerichtshof
also man denkt karlsruhe muss sich damit
beschäftigen ist aber nicht so denn die
erste instanz waren amtsgericht deswegen
landgericht hat jetzt entschieden und
die nächste instanz wäre dann quasi
deckel also bayerische oberste
wie keep you posted würde ich sagen
so und damit kommen wir zum gerechten
urteil das heißt heute du mitgebracht
corinna ich bin sehr gespannt ob ich das
auch gerecht werden finden werde was
hast du da kann ich jetzt schon im
wetter abgeben dass du das willst
denn es ist wirklich ein fall der uns
gott sei dank mal ganz sorgenfrei
hinterlässt niveau wie nicht irgendwie
empathie heucheln müssen oder haben
müssen also reichen wären vielleicht in
ordnung aber
wir hatten ja auch wirklich ziemlich
herzzerreißende geschichten hier schon
in unserem gerechten urteil der woche
vielleicht nochmal für all diejenigen
die dann neu hinzu gekommen sind das ist
so ein bisschen die stelle in unserem
podcast wo wir auch mal zeigen wollen
wie gerecht jura sein kann und 16 das
ist auch die stelle wo es ein bisschen
menschen nur sehr menschlich wo
vielleicht die juristischen argumente
nicht ganz so stichhaltig sind sondern
kurzen darum geht dass wir hier mit so
ein bisschen ein wohlgefühl aus der
sendung gleiten ja das vielleicht als
kleine erklärung zu diesem teil des
podcast genau es geht wirklich
tatsächlich gar nicht immer so sehr
darum ist das jetzt juristisch super
begründet wie ist das einzuordnen was
bedeutet das in einem größeren kontext
sondern wir suchen uns wirklich in aller
regel rein ergebnisorientiert ein urteil
im ergebnis aus gucken uns das an und
sagen mögen wir das ergebnis ja oder
nein und hier war der protagonist der
fahrer eines tiefer gelegten ferrari f40
ja das klingt so als wüsstest du wieder
nicht dem blassen schimmer also ich
hoffe er ist schön rot und flach wie
eine flunder wie man sich so ferraris
vorstellt ich wollte eigentlich auch mal
den listenpreis raus aber ich muss offen
stehen im ganzen park gas embargo ist
jetzt auch untergegangen also wir
stellen uns vor ist ein unfassbar teures
gefährt tiefergelegt mit viel fahrspaß
zumindest für den fahrer oder die
fahrerin so
jedenfalls eine zeitlang hatte dieser
fahrer spaß bis er durch eine kleine
seitenstraße fuhr und dabei überquerte
er ein kanal dek decke derweil
offensichtlich ja aus dem boden heraus
ragte und zwar nicht nur geringfügig wer
wie es in dem urteil heißt also da muss
ein bisschen was schiefgegangen sein das
ding wagte eben raus alle normalen autos
hatten damit kein problem offensichtlich
sind jedenfalls super gefahren das so
meine vermutung nur dann kam eben der
ferrari ja und weil er ihnen so
serienmäßig tiefer gelegt war hat das
leider nicht drüber geschafft so und
dann kam es zu einem sachschaden und wie
das offensichtlich bei diesen ferraris
sind so ist ist das nicht ein ding was
man für ein paar tausend euro beheben
kann sondern das war mal ein sachschaden
in höhe von schlappen 60.000 euro ja
normalerweise kriegt man ein ganzes auto
dafür ja auch ein gutes rennen fahren
weiß man halt auch was man sich zu mehr
so und hier übrigens als kleiner
schlenker hat übrigens nicht der ferrari
fahrer selber geklagt sondern die
versicherung der war wohl klug und hatte
eine kaskoversicherung und die musste
dafür offensichtlich aufkommen und diese
versicherung hat sich dann diesen oder
wollte sich den schaden von der gemeinde
als trägerin der
straßenbaulast wieder zurückholen mit
dem argument macht mal eure straßen ja
klar also ich meine das liegt doch auf
der hand wir haben hier diesen kanal
decke ist doch klar dass man als tiefer
gelegter ferrari da nicht rüberkommt und
dann aufgeschlitzt wird von unten so und
das ist natürlich
ja schuld der gemeinde die natürlich
dafür hätte sorgen müssen dass das ganze
ordentlich verschlossen ist das
landgericht hat schon gesagt nie so
sehen wir das nicht da wird ja immer
geprüft ob die gemeinde eine
verkehrssicherungspflicht verletzt hat
ja das ist dann immer eine juristische
fachterminus in diesem fall verkehrs
ganz ernst genommen ganz wörtlich eine
verkehrssicherung der ich dir und das lg
hat auch schon gesagt nee das ist nicht
hätte mal aufpassen müssen war die kurze
antwort des landgerichts natürlich
juristischer formuliert so und jetzt hat
das
oberlandesgericht koblenz entschieden
und hat das ganze bestätigt der wir sind
leider erst jetzt darauf aufmerksam
geworden sonst hätten wir natürlich auch
schon das landgericht als gerechtes
urteil hier in dieser sendung gehabt so
erging es eben darum hätte die gemeinde
der maßnahme heben müssen
grundsätzlich natürlich schon ja wenn
das sowie dafür sorgt dass jetzt hier
der autos reihenweise beschädigt werden
aber achtung hier ist es eben so dass
der autofahrer durch sein tiefer
gelegten ferrari selbst zur
risikoerhöhung beigetragen hat ja durch
die tatsache dass der eben tiefer gelegt
war
und das hätte er kompensieren müssen
durch erhöhte eigene aufmerksamkeit ja
hat er wohl offensichtlich nicht
jedenfalls ist er darüber gebrettert
vielleicht hätte er dann noch daran
vorbeifahren können oder zumindest mal
kurz auf den
auf den
fußgängerweg naja jedenfalls hat ist
jetzt sozusagen vom olg entschieden
klargestellt dass die
verkehrssicherungspflicht beinhaltet
eben nicht die pflicht mit erheblichen
kosten für die allgemeinheit dafür sorge
zu tragen dass die straße auch für nicht
alltagstaugliche fahrzeuge
visum ferrari gefahrlos nutzbar ist ja
also letztendlich und das findest du
geringer natürlich das finde ich schon
recht also ich finde übrigens also die
bezeichnung in ordnung oder sehr schön
auch dass der ferrari mal als nicht
alltagstaugliches auto
bezeichnet wird ich finde das überhaupt
nicht in ordnung ich meine der ferrari
ist doch zugelassen zum straßenverkehr
und der ferrari ist serienmäßig tiefer
gelegt wenn ich einfach ein auto kaufe
das serienmäßig halt so ist und dann
wird es auch noch zugelassen zum
straßenverkehr ich finde das ein skandal
ist ein skandal dass die gemeinde sich
auf ihre ferrari-fahrer acht gibt ja ein
bisschen schon denn ich meine es muss
halt eigentlich schon meine meinung
dafür sorge tragen dass straßen auch
normal befahrbar sind auch mit
tiefergelegten autos jedenfalls wenn das
nicht gegen irgendwelche es die
vorschriften oder wo auch immer das
geregelt sein mag verstößt aber man muss
ja mal ehrlich sagen dass fast nie eine
stadt oder eine kommune dafür haftet
wenn ihre strafe auch wenn ihre straßen
katastrophal richtig und dann warum der
curry das ist es vielleicht ne also ist
auch hier wieder nicht 100-prozentig
juristisch argumentiert aber natürlich
aus einem lebensgefühl heraus als ich
meinen manchen straßen sehen ja aus ganz
ehrlich köln wäre wenn ihr wenn köln
dafür haften müsste für jedes schlagloch
bahn wer die steuerlast man ja auch mal
ehrlicherweise sagen und wieso sollte
dann quasi der ferrari mehr verlangen
können als der normale autofahrer und
hier ist es ja ich weiss lässt sich
schon hören dass man sagen muss dass man
auch wenn man weiß dass sein auto tiefer
gelegt ist dann fährt man ja nun auch
anders also das stimmt ja nun auch sohn
also man fährt er dann eben gerade nicht
die hohen bordstein hoch und man hätte
glaube ich also wenn es wirklich stimmt
dass das nicht nur geringfügig
aufgebockt war ja dann muss man das
natürlich auch gesehen haben ja und wer
vielleicht bin ich auch gerade
traumatisiert weil wir vor kurzem mit
unserem camper in so ein fettes
schlagloch gefahren sind dass wir nicht
sehen konnten und natürlich werden wir
dann auch keine stadt verklagen man muss
sagen vielleicht bin ich traumatisiert
aufgrund persönlicher betroffenheit aber
ich finde weder den grundsatz dass die
kommunen dafür haften gut noch dass der
arme ferrari fahren ja ich würde ja auch
die muss ich jetzt mal eine lanze
brechen die vergabe hätte das habe ich
auch meine wette wirklich jetzt verloren
und das uns wieder ein aufruf an unsere
hörerinnen und hörer ja bitte schreibt
uns ja und sagt uns welcher meinung er
zu neigt ja so und bittet ist mich nicht
es ist nicht so dass ich den verein oder
mich ja könnte auch sein dass wir hier
ganz viele ferrari fans haben ja es
könnte ich sozusagen als herbst loses
stück hier gebrannt man werde gut wir
sind sehr das ist eben auch etwas also
man muss sagen ich meine dem parade
erfahren hat das sei vielleicht hier
nochmal gesagt ist ja nichts böses
widerfahren denn die versicherung hat ja
gezahlt das wird dann wieder was meinst
du das größte in der hochstufen
wenn damit man gar nicht mehr spaß da
hinten dranhängen so also jetzt über ein
schuljahr damit gerecht und ungerecht es
gibt aber auch wirklich schlimmeres im
leben wie wir jetzt jeden tag wieder
erinnert werden wir danken an dieser
stelle für die aufmerksamkeit freuen uns
über feedback wie jede woche und wir
möchten jetzt mal wirklich aufs neue
sehr enthusiastisch darauf hinweisen wir
freuen uns wirklich über feedback
anregungen
auch themen ideen wir haben heute und
kritiker aber heute wurde übrigens auch
eine themen idee eines hörers noch
aufgegriffen das war auch der teil mit
den tankstellen preisen die ging auch
darauf zurück dass der aufmerksame hörer
sich was gewünscht haben also wir sind
auch so ein bisschen wünsch dir was ich
sage nochmal die e mailadresse einspruch
podcast
faz.de ansonsten wünschen wir ihnen
allen euch allen und tierliebe pia
schöne woche es bleibt uns gewogen
[Musik]